[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
débrief du dock pour ce nouveau numéro
on va revenir sur la figure du général
du d'un personnage central du
documentaire réalisé pour rta par artyom
vorobiev émirats il barine ils ont filmé
et raconter l'expédition archéologique
franco-russe parti à la recherche de la
dépouille de charles etienne gudin et
général de la grande armée et amine
napoléon il est mort lors d'une bataille
près de smolensk en russie en 1812 et
son corps n'avait jamais été retrouvé
alors qu'il est est il que représente
cela pour la france et la russie la
découverte de ces ossements le secret du
général dumas ont débrief aujourd'hui
avec christian bourdeilles président du
souvenir napoléonien tristan bourdais
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté de nous
éclairer encore davantage sur le général
gudin et l'expédition qui a mené à la
découverte de sa dépouille
alors peut-être pour commencer une
réaction à ce documentaire en tant que
président du souvenir napoléonien quelle
émotion avez vous ressenti en regardant
ces images de cette expédition
bonjour d'abord c'est un film qui est
tout à fait passionnant parce que ça
nous permet de mieux comprendre qu'en
histoire rien n'est prévu tout peut être
découvert à nouveau et c'est vrai que
général gaudin avait disparu on savait
qu'ils étaient enterrés à smolensk
mais où on n'en savait rien et de voir
comment justement à travers ce film
comme on est parti à la recherche du
général gudin avec les tâtonnements on
n'a pas trouvé du premier coup et ça ça
montre bien ce que peut-être la
recherche historique encore aujourd'hui
une aventure une aventure scientifique
avec des scientifiques de haut niveau
qu'ils étaient capables d'identifier
très rapidement si on se fourvoyait ou
pas et ça c'est vraiment tout à fait
intéressant parce que ça donne envie
il ya un côté détective au delà donc de
de l'épopée napoléonienne de la campagne
de russie de 1812
il ya ce côté encore une fois recherches
historiques recherche de détectives donc
à la recherche d'un général disparu
et quand on a été vraiment très heureux
de retrouver la trace et a eu un écho
tout à fait formidable c'est ça qui est
tout à fait intéressant donc de nos
jours en 2020 alors on va revenir bien
entendu sur cet écho sur la figure du
général du nord mais peut-être un rappel
un rappel sur le contexte on est en 1812
la france envahi la russie impériale
aujourd'hui français et russes main dans
la main pour retrouver les ossements du
général ghislain qu'est ce que ce
général napoléonien représente-t-il en
russie d'abord voir ce que je voudrais
rappeler c'est que au départ on appelle
ça aujourd'hui la campagne de russie
mais c'est pas la campagne aussi c'est
la campagne de pologne et avec un
empereur napoléon 1er qui souhaitait
revenir donc à l'accord de tilsit et je
crois que cet accord de tilsit on
comprend pas bien encore toutes les
conséquences que cela a pu avoir pour la
première fois la france et la russie se
parlent encore aujourd'hui ça paraît
tout à fait évident à l'époque ce
n'était pas complètement évident est ce
que la russie continuait à chercher une
place dans le concert européen et cette
campagne de pologne au départ est
devenue au fil des semaines une campagne
de russie alors ce général gudin
effectivement et d'ailleurs dans le film
car les nuts qui étudie on connaissait
pas très bien le guide a effectivement
il ya que les spécialistes qui pouvait
connaître le général gudin alors que
c'est une grande figure grandes figures
de la grande armée
quelqu'un qui a fait ses études comme
s'est rappelée dans deux dans le film
ses études à brienne brienne c'est un
petit village de champagne ou napoléon a
débarqué parlant à peine le français par
l'anc ans est il complètement isolé et
gudin a été donc un ami et je peux vous
dire que napoléon bonaparte à brienne
dans ses années de jeunesse avait très
peu d'amis et parmi ses amis les plus
fidèles
il y avait ce général gudin gudin de la
sablonnière ce qui veut dire que cuba
est un noble but d'un n'ya pas donc du
peuple
c'est un noble qui choisit la carrière
des armes
sur les conseils de son oncle et surtout
quelques années après le général gudin
c'est un officier qui va faire le choix
de la révolution française il y a
environ 25% des généraux de lempire la
révolution de l' empire qui sont des
nobles et gudin d'assab ionnaires fait
partie de ces nobles qui up qui font le
choix de la révolution ce qui n'était
pas complètement évident vous imaginé se
retrouver officiers donc de l'armée de
la république française de la révolution
française on est forcément soupçonné et
ce général il sera toujours fidèle
fidèle à la révolution mais aussi fidèle
à l' empire et il sera toujours donc un
ami proche de lenteur napoléon 1er
continueront à se tutoyer et ce sera
donc une grande figure de la grande
armée au delà de ce côté relationnel
goût d'un de la sablière donc sera un
des plus grands généraux dont deux
divisions de la grande armée
et surtout il frappe est parti donc des
plus grands engagements notamment donc à
la bataille de diên à howard stadt
l'état orchad il fait partie avec le
maréchal davout détroit divisionnaire ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui les trois
immortel général friands général morand
et le général gudin qui vont à
l'occasion de la bataille de rouerge
date résister donc vaillamment à l'armée
prussienne et ça c'est quelque chose qui
est vraiment très important et puis
guide on va le retrouver à aller là-haut
donc en prusse russie aujourd'hui et on
va le retrouver
bien sûr dans toutes les campagnes on va
le retrouver à wagram
bien évidemment il sera gouverneur donc
du château de fontainebleau
bref un grand professionnel et c'est
vrai que il avait disparu
bon il y en a eu d'autres qui ont
disparu mais parmi les 2000 généraux de
la révolution et de l' empire
le général gul un fait partie donc des
divisionnaires les plus chevronnés les
plus fidèles sur lesquelles on pouvait
compter et finalement c'est ce qui va
causer sa perte puisque on en parlera
tout à l'heure au delà de valentine
agora pas très loin de smolensk il y a
un problème à régler
napoléon fait appel à qui il fait à
l un de ses meilleurs divisionnaire
alors je vous propose maintenant de
revenir au début de cette expédition et
finalement on l'évoquait tout à l'heure
on se rend compte que c'est pas gagné on
va écouter un frédéric lemaire c'est
l'un des chercheurs français qui mène
l'expédition du général ou d'un on les
écoute on en parle après nous avons
localisé implanté l'emprise d'un sondage
dans laxe les bastions shine of
effectivement les premiers résultats
indiquent que que la tombe du général de
la neuveville ne se trouve pas ne feront
pas cher c'est une déception
effectivement mais moi je suis pas plus
affecté par cette part ce travail parce
que c'est mon travail de chercheurs de
soumettre des hypothèses d'aller sur le
terrain et de vérifier alors on le voit
au début du documentaire une hypothèse
donc qui ne se concrétise pas on est
déçu alors quand les chercheurs français
partent en russie
finalement quels sont les éléments qui
les ont à leur connaissance comme les
chercheurs russes pour s'orienter vers
le lieu de la dépouille
alors on n'a que quelques documents donc
à la fois donc général le jeune et donc
de ségur et c'est des documents qui se
contredisent pas forcément mais qui
donne pas les précisions nécessaires
pour l'un donc on fait le choix de pas
l'enterrez n'importe où ce général gudin
qui encore une fois lorsqu'il est
emporté par donc un boulet dès le 19
août il demeure que le 21 août
donc vous imaginez les souffrances qu'il
a pu endurer puisqu'il a eu donc une
première jambe amputée et ensuite
napoléon donc à donner donc l'ordre
d'amputer la deuxième jambe parce que la
gangrène donc menaçait d'emporter le
général c'est ce qui va arriver
donc il faut bien se remettre dans le
contexte donc de doute 1812
donc nous sommes déjà le 21 août nous
sommes
donc en pleine campagne smolensk donc a
été prise donc smolensk que c'est une
bataille qui va être extrêmement rude
mais aussi un échec puisque naples et on
pensait pouvoir encerclé une partie de
l'armée impériale russe
c'est pas ce qui va se passer puisque
juno mettra quelques temps pour arriver
donc il ya de la résistance donc c'est
une retraite de l'armée impériale russe
qui se fait donc non pas en désordre
mais dans le plus grand ordre et donc il
ya au delà de valentine agora donc une
colline à emporter et manifestement le
maréchal ney donc à des difficultés il
en fait part à naples en deux premiers
et il se trouve que le général budin est
à côté de lui encore une fois c'est ce
que je disais tout à l'heure que d'un
est infidèle
ils visitaient un monastère il y a un
problème à régler
napoléon se tourner du daim et là on lui
dit il faut aider le maréchal ney
emporté ses sept collines donc il va
être comme je viens de le dire donc
blessé et donc l'idée ça va être deux on
va l'enterrer ou encore une fois on n'a
pas le temps de penser vraiment autre
chose
la grande armée continue continue son
avancée comme vous le savez il y aura la
bataille de borodino donc au mois de
septembre puis l'arrivée de la grande
armée à moscou le 14 septembre
donc les choses vont très vite et il
faut organiser donc l'enterrement très
rapidement donc du corps du général
gudin donc certains disent bon on va pas
le mettre dans un champ et on va le
mettre dans un lieu un peu symbolique
donc donc l'idée c'était de dire ben on
a dû l'enterrer donc dans un bastion
mais à l'intérieur donc en dix ans il
sera protégé il y aura evra rien
normalement ce bastion
avec peut-être une tour ce à quoi on
pense serait donc la sépulture donc la
plus évidente
et puis il ya une autre théorie qui dit
ben en fait on parle dont certains d'un
bastion mais d'un monticule à la manière
gauloise où jadis lorsqu on enterrait
donc les grands chefs gaulois
eh bien on faisait donc un monticule à
tumulus et à l'intérieur duquel est bien
on mettait donc des armes
tout ce qu'on pouvait pour justement
glorifier l'action donc de ce vaillant
guerrier
donc il y avait ces deux théories on
sait tourner d'abord vers un bastion
donc une forteresse en disant c'est
peut-être là qu'on va le trouver de
manière évidente parce qu'on se dit par
les gens de l'époque n'ont pas cherché
il voulait un endroit protégé
il y avait une grande tour avec un poids
ils l'ont enterré dedans ça paraît que
complètement évident donc c'est pour ça
que dans le film on voit les premières
recherches se font d'autant plus que
smolensk a beaucoup subi de
bombardements donc pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale donc il reste simplement
quelques quelques traces et puis
effectivement on imagine donc les gens
fouillent et des dépêches
le film retrace bien ce côté là très
rapidement mais vous imaginez donc pour
les équipes c'est pas forcément toujours
très très glorieux de bon de prendre une
bêche et puis on y va on sait pas du
tout si on va trouver quelque chose ça a
un côté un petit peu fait fait qui dieu
lorsqu'on bêche retirent de la terre
entre quelque chose on est heureux
lorsqu'on trouve rien on se dit mais
qu'est ce qu'on est en train de faire là
et ça a été justement la force de cette
équipe de pas abandonner et de continuer
pierre valinox qui donc a joué un très
grand rôle pour que justement le moral
des troupes ne baisse pas et de dire bon
essayons de réfléchir on parle d'un
bastion
est-ce que c'est forcément sous une tour
est ce que ça peut pas être ailleurs
et on parle de tumulus justement et
peut-être que je finalement c'est là
qu'il faudra donc aller chercher donc ce
que je viens de dire tout à l'heure
c'est vos pense qu'on va trouver
forcément des armes
peut-être des boulets de canon peut-être
des d'autres armes blanches
enfin bref on va trouver des indices et
ce qui est quand même tout à fait
intéressant c'est que ton kg se met à
faire la deuxième fouille mais ne trouve
rien un rôdeur on trouve le corps donc
ce qu'il en reste donc le corps
squelettique donc du général mais où
sont passés donc les armes les uniformes
dont on parle d'un faisceau d'armes on
trouve rien et ça pas du était évident
forcément de garder le moral on a trouvé
un corps est ce que c'est vraiment le
général y avait pas beaucoup d' indices
en plus c'est ça qui m'étonne beaucoup
parce qu'on pourrait dire il était
enterré avec son uniforme des médailles
bref des de quelques métaux que l'on
pourrait retrouver et surtout encore une
fois où sont passés les armes
donc le faisceau d'armes qu'on a dû
disposer sur le corps du général gudin
tout ça a disparu ce qui reste quand
même un petit peu mystérieux mais il
s'est passé beaucoup de choses
évidemment entre 1812 et 2019
alors on va continuer à parler de la
figure du général début d'un et ses
expéditions avec vous christian
bourdeilles mais avant je vous propose
de faire une petite pause on se retrouve
tout de suite
[Musique]
et le secret du général ghislain on
continue d'en parler avec christian
bourdeilles alors on parlait bien
entendu de cette expédition qui au début
finalement un petit peu de mal à se
lancer avant d'y revenir peut-être
revenir sur le général gueu d'un c'était
une figure nationale il était connu à
l'époque
quels étaient les grands aspects de sa
personnalité alors le général gul est
encore une fois c est un homme qui
choisit donc la révolution et c'est un
grand professionnel
c'est quelqu'un qu'on retrouve dans
toute l'épopée de l'armée du rhin ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'il n'est pas à
cette époque là un proche que ce soit du
général bonaparte ou du premier consul
il fait partie de l'armée du rhin il
fait pas partie de l'armée d'italie ce
qui est toujours donc très important il
n'est pas en egypte par exemple mais il
est un brillant général de l'armée du
rhin notamment donc en 1800 puisque il
fait plus partie donc de l'action de
l'armée de la république française donc
en allemagne après la bataille de
marengo dépôt du rôle tout à fait
important il est populaire il est c'est
un général qui n'est pas forcément
populaires encore une fois c'est
quelqu'un qui est très attentif donc
à ces droits il ya des épisodes ou lors
de manifestations officielles il trouve
qu'on ne rend pas assez hommage au
militaire donc ils bousculent un petit
peu donc les fonctionnaires civils en
disant c'est à l'armée d'occuper donc
les premiers rangs donc c'est quelqu'un
de dur c'est pas forcément quelqu'un qui
arrondit les angles mais c'est quelqu'un
sur lequel on peut compter
et encore une fois vous savez que le
maréchal davout fait partie peut-être du
maréchal le plus brillant donc de
napoléon et
et c'est par hasard si goudin fait
partie de ces trois divisionnaire favori
du maréchal davout sur lequel on peut
compter
donc c'est un homme austère qui est dur
qui fait très attention à ce que les
soldats donc fassent leur devoir
et s'il n'est pas populaire il est
respecté ça sans aucun problème et
lorsque il va être atteint par ce boulet
de canon le 19 août 1812
ça va être une grande perte et tous
leurs considérera que la perte de bus da
est terrible alors un grand militaire
l'histoire du général lui d'un c'est
aussi une histoire familiale
je veux vous propose de regarder cet
aspect qu'on voit dans le documentaire
avec albéric d'orléans c'est le
descendant du général gudin on regarde
et on en parle voilà donc entre le
général du d'amour à ce pollen sq et mes
enfants vous pouvez comptez vous avez
ici huit générations
donc à ça sa mort gaudin avait demandé à
napoléon de prendre soin de ses enfants
napoléon a tenu parole et il a demandé à
la veuve du général si elle pouvait lui
confier son fils aîné pour le servir
comme page
ça c'est l'être que napoléon avait écrit
à l'épousé du général gudin pour le pôle
informé que son mari était mort à
smolensk
c'est donc il lui dit qui partage sa
peine
qui pense à elles et à sa famille et lui
explique comment les comment les choses
vont se passer pour eux dans le futur
alors on découvre la proximité entre le
général guisan et napoléon vous en
parlais tout à l'heure
est ce que sa famille a cherché
auparavant à rapatrier le corps du
général gudin ils ont cherché mais pas
forcément très très longtemps
d'ailleurs on peut se poser donc une
question pourquoi napoléon donc n'a pas
cherché rapatrier le corps du général
guide a vu que ça nous bluffer éléments
de réponse que je n'ai pas de re
d'éléments de réponse aujourd'hui ça
fait partie justement du les mystères du
général gudin pourquoi napoléon pourtant
qu'ils étaient très attachés
donc à ce général n'at-il pas d'abord
lui ce que vous parliez de sa famille
mais pourquoi napoléon n'avait pas
cherché à rapatrier le corps du général
gudin comme on a rapatrié le corps du
général kléber qui a été assassiné au
caire le 14 juin 1800 le général des ex
après la bataille de marengo son corps
n'a pas été enterré et abandonné
pourrait parler du maréchal lannes qui
est aussi donc mort donc
aisling et le corps du maréchal lannes a
mis un an pour revenir donc à paris et
aujourd'hui donc enterré au panthéon
avec donc d'autres officiers serre est
pour moi quelque chose d'assez
mystérieux alors je sais qu encore une
fois lors de la campagne de russie
l'armée française où l'armée européenne
puisque c'est l'armé des daevas nations
avancées très rapidement puis vous
connaissez les suites de la campagne de
russie
mais pour moi ça reste un petit peu
mystérieux pourquoi napoléon n'at-il pas
cherché immédiatement rapatrier le corps
que général bid a en tous les cas
l'équipe russe avait depuis le début en
tête un lieu où devait être enterré en
général gudin la citadine la citadelle
de la ville de smolensk qui est
aujourd'hui un parc il n'y avait pas de
certitude mais cette fois c'était la
bonne
et beaucoup de joie 1 pour 1 pierre
maninno ce qui à l'origine de cette
expédition on regarde nous avons obtenu
des résultats alors que la probabilité
de trouver quelque chose n'était même
pas 2 1 sur 100 mais de 1 sur 1000
mais dans ce cas c'est de la chance oui
de la chance on peut affirmer à affirmer
définitivement que c'est général de la
rue il n'ya même pas sans le corps déjà
juste la position pour commencer la
position du corps ici au centre avec les
archers à presse en parle juste
exclusivement du corps il ya deux choses
vraiment très importante
il ya la jambe la jambe déjà coupé
hauteur au dessus du genou comme dans
les mémoires du
du docteur de napoléon du chirurgien vue
napoléon et la seconde jambe aussi
qu'ils étaient abîmées on voit les
traces de comme quoi ça a été touchée
désolé trace d'impact
[Musique]
il y en a beaucoup en fait il ya tout
qui se mélangent puisque c'est un an de
travail pour préparer tout le projet
depuis le début
et quand vous arrivez à dire au but à
trouver c'est un moment historique
donc parler seulement pour moi je pense
pour nos deux pays donc ça ne s'est
énormément d'émotion en même temps de
toute façon j'aurais pas arrêtés sont
trouvés way
[Musique]
alors un moment historique pour nos deux
pays nous dit pierre am and is not
malinowski au fond que représente cette
découverte à la fois pour la russie et
pour la france
je pense que la campagne de 1812
campagne de pologne puis campagne de
russie est un moment fondateur de la
relation franco russe ça me paraît
complètement évident d'ailleurs
n'oublions pas que les soldats de la
grande armée qui pénètre en russie sont
des soldats de la révolution française
il est très difficile de séparer
révolution et empire et l'éruption de
cette armée qui est porteuse donc des
idées la révolution comme le code civil
est un événement aussi un événement
culturel et c'est ça que il faut
célébrer aussi je parlais de tilsit tout
à l'heure de l'accord de tilsit qui a
été signé donc en 1807
encore une fois cet accord de sites à
mon avis et fondateur de l'amitié entre
la france et la russie ce qui n'était
pas du tout évident quand il faut
regarder les relations diplomatiques la
russie peine à exister dans le concert
européen et c'est napoléon qui justement
après la bataille du de free et de
l'envié bon on sait assez battu ça
suffit je ne demande rien donc aux arts
je veux simplement qu'il me dise qu'il
est en lutte contre l'angleterre la
première puissance du monde
je vous le rappelle donc à cette époque
et napoléon dit si vous êtes d'accord
avec ça la paix est faite et il n'y a
pas eu d'autres tractations donc encore
une fois ces années 1807 1812 sont tout
à fait fondatrice dont l'histoire
j'aurais quand même c'était une guerre
et paix de tolstoï bien évidemment donc
c'est un grand moment et surtout de
retrouver quelque chose de nouveau on
croyait qu'on avait tout découvert qu'on
savait tout sur cette campagne de russie
et bien non il y avait encore un élément
qui nous manquait et comme vous le savez
on va s'acheminer donc en 2022 vers un
nouvel anniversaire de cette campagne de
russie
et aujourd'hui comment diplomatiquement
cette découverte raisons telles entre la
france et la russie par mois je pense
qu'elle arrive au meilleur moment
parce que je pense que les liens entre
la russie et la france ont des liens
historiques et le fait qu' on retrouve
cette figure et que ça mobilise donc
l'énergie de nos chercheurs de nos
historiens en russie et en france je
trouve que c'est tout à fait
enthousiasmant et ce qui prouve qu'on
peut se retrouver facilement sur cette
page d'histoire
encore une fois qui est fondatrice de
notre relation entre la russie et la
france comme va le montrer tout le 19e
siècle
je pense aux officiers les cas briest
qui est la première tentative
révolutionnaire en russie ces officiers
la plupart ont des épouses française par
le français et son pétri de l'histoire
de la révolution et ça arrive au bon
moment
on avait besoin de ça et moi je me
félicite bien sûr du retour avec
l'accord des autorités russes de la
dépouille du général gudin aux invalides
ça va être un grand moment puis il est
une grande célébration commune on peut
on peut imaginer une grande célébration
commune franco russe pour le
rapatriement du général guide absolument
puisque aujourd'hui d'après mes
informations ce rapatriement est prévu
le 5 mai donc 2021 l'occasion du
bicentenaire de la mort de l'empereur
napoléon 1er donc vous imaginez que ça
se fera pas tout à fait discrètement et
donc le souvenir napoléonien bien
évidemment est partie prenante de cette
opération nous allons mobiliser nos
adhérents il y aura des airs au
constituaient donc en uniforme pour
mettre l'accent sur justement la grande
armée lorsqu'on parle du bicentenaire de
la mort de napoléon 1er
c'est aussi un hommage à tous ces
soldats tous ces officiers qui ont donné
leur vie pour l'empiré français
christian brodhag c'est passionnant
malheureusement le temps passe très vite
mais peut-être pour conclure il nous
reste quelques secondes
cette question aujourd'hui on parle
beaucoup des déboulonnage de statut
celle de l'empereur à la roche-sur-yon
napoléon bonaparte a été elle aussi
concernés qu'est ce que ça vous évoque
ses déboulonnage de statut cette remise
en cause de l'histoire finalement
d'abord c'est extrêmement triste c'est
facile de valence et de la peinture
rouge sur sur une statue de déboulonner
une statue ça n'aide pas beaucoup à
comprendre l'histoire
moi si ça permet donc justement aux gens
de s'intéresser qu'est ce qui s'est
passé pour essayer de comprendre
en l'occurrence pour napoléon bonaparte
napoléon n'a jamais rétabli l'esclavagé
il l'a maintenu dans certaines colonies
qui avait été occupé par les troupes
britanniques par exemple en guyane on
n'a pas rétabli l'esclavagé
donc c'est beaucoup plus complexe il
faut prendre le temps donc encore une
fois moins que les gens s'intéressent à
l'histoire je le trouve ça tout à fait
passionnant maintenant il faut que donc
les choses soient organisées et c'était
aussi le rôle du souvenir napoléonien
donc d'organiser donc un tel débat et de
prendre le temps simplement de lire et
j'espère de dépasser ce genre de débat
un peu un peu stérile puisque c'est
toute l'histoire qui est remise en cause
et à ce moment là si on remet tout en
cause
sans prendre le temps de comprendre ça
sera donc un épisode simplement triste
espérons que ça puisse susciter des
débats et des échanges
on arrive au terme de cette émission
merci beaucoup christian bourdeilles de
nous avoir accompagnés pour ce débrief
du doc je rappelle que vous êtes
président du souvenir napoléonien
le documentaire le secret du général
guide ainsi que cette émission
elles sont bien évidemment à revoir sur
notre site internet
rt france pointé vais également à
découvrir en podcast
merci pour votre fidélité à bientôt sur
rt france
[Musique]
à